u.s airlines refunded 12.8 billion
dollars of travelers in 2020 12.8
billion dollars
this is a fox business story 11 u.s
airlines issued 12.84 billion dollars in
cash refunds to customers in 2020 as the
coronal virus pandemic
appended the travel industry and the
head of the industry trade group
airlines for america a4a said in a
letter to lawmakers
on friday calgo said the cash refunds
which counter for 20
of airlines revenue last year came on
top of billions of dollars of travel
credits
that are now being used as a rapid clip
to book
fresh flights the redemption of voucher
currently accounts for 10 or 15
carriers monthly ticket sales and is
expected to increase
in coming months as the pandemic winds
down and markets and
venues reopen thoughts no sympathy
whatsoever for the airlines
something zero because a they got 25
billion in bailout money at the
beginning of the pandemic
they've always got their hand out
they're always getting taken care of
zero sympathy that's my first reaction
number one i don't believe them
i don't believe they gave back 12.8
billion dollars
so i'm just telling you right now
documented though that's going to be
like an audit if you say it doesn't
matter he doesn't believe it that's fine
let him have his opinion
maybe it could be fuzzy math it could be
mysterious account he's got a point you
get 25 billion dollars of bailouts
yeah i fly a lot we all fly a lot yeah
you actually fly
a lot i've never gotten money back from
an airline it's a credit on another
flight so if
if they're trying to disguise that as
giving money back meanwhile that money's
working for them we got to get more
to make the calls you got to make brawl
make the calls you'll get you'll get
more than credit back but go ahead
that's true that's a good point right
you know i need to get after shut up
but then i always know that there's
another flight coming so i might as well
just put it somewhere else
um so anyway that's my two reactions a
no sympathy whatsoever
b i don't believe you you don't believe
the math that's fine tom
hey what there isn't some sort of
distorted accounting principles that
could be happening
i'm not i'm not arguing with you i'm
just saying let the boy watch
let him do his thing i'm letting you do
your thing do you have any opinions yeah
i do i think actually
uh right when the pandemic happened i
had actually a bunch of flights that
were booked
yeah from march you know that in the
insurance conference everyone has their
spring meetings
in march and april i had spring meetings
galore and
being in miami the hub is american
american airlines so i had a lot of
flights booked to american
actually got to give a shout out to
american they were actually pretty damn
good
they reimbursed any flights they uh they
said that there's no uh
charges whatsoever for for changing
flights for cancer fights
all good they were actually pretty
decent but the one thing that that i
thought about
um with you know the the bailout money
is the the speech that chamas had
chamath palapatiya had
at the beginning of the pandemic where
basically he said let him fail
let him fail and people were this was on
cnbc people were shocked what do you
mean let him fail he's like
if you he's right though yeah you know
that's part of capitalism is the freedom
to fail yeah
so if you took all your money that you
received from the trump tax breaks in
and you used it for stock buybacks and
you didn't use it to
make your company stronger or or invest
in the people or whatever you needed to
do
to make your business healthier and you
just use it for stock buybacks
you report you sow right so actually
when jamaat said that
that was actually the first time that
i've heard of him i was like what was
this guy talking about letting airplane
airlines fail what what what what he's a
smart and then it it kind of resonated
with me especially
with all the bailouts that happened yeah
uh since the pandemic what about you
here's what i would say about this i
think what airlines by the way just so
you know restaurants
the other day i saw an article by
bloomberg that said uh
actually instead of 50 of restaurants
going out of business only 14
of restaurants went permanently out of
business i'm like only yeah
14 of restaurants when i only only 14
american population it's only no no no
no what do you listen
but then they'll flip and they'll say
2.6 million americans die so how come
you don't say only what do you mean only
of restaurants went out of business this
is a bloomberg remember of that fourteen
percent eighty-six percent of the
businesses that are restaurants probably
are hanging on by a thread
there's no they have no other option
yeah i mean it's a family thing so just
because they're not out of business
doesn't mean they're like
surviving or threatening origins are
like this margins
even smaller in restaurants way smaller
margins are like this in restaurants and
margins are like this and area exactly
when they're
airline airline industries margins are
like this
if i'm looking at this right now here's
what i'm thinking about
forget about the 12.8 billion dollars
after payback to travelers forget about
the 25 billion dollars that they got
for uh what do you call it the bailouts
forget about all that stuff
every single airline company out there
if the ceo
is going to do anything right right now
here's what i'd be doing
i would have every single c-suite
executive of mine
in the company read the book blue ocean
strategy
i'm going to have a conference call and
say guys let me tell you where we are
right now
we need to read two books one is blue
ocean strategy
and the other book is uh let me give you
the name it's the story of apple kai
what's
not apple ibm kai what's the apple ibm
book i had you read
what is it how elephant stands
i had this as my book for executives
last month that we went through
uh uh uh uh who says elephants can't
dance can you put that up there so
people can't see it i don't make money
off this i don't know who wrote
i couldn't tell you the author's name
but i had every single one of my
executives read this because the
recommendation was given to me by david
vega a new ceo that we hired a guy's a
flipping amazing guy and he said pat why
don't we read this book so we read the
book
it's how the ibm ceo came in and cleaned
house
okay every airline company
needs to read blue ocean strategy i
think by w.c chen
and they need to read this book uh who
says elephants can dance
because your bigger problem isn't covid
your bigger problem is the last 12
months changed people's behavior
and if this behavior stays forever you
are
screwed if this behavior doesn't change
forget about how much money you got
dealing here forget about all this
buyback stuff
you may be going out of business if you
don't change your current
business model business model is broken
today the way they're doing it they have
to figure out a different dude by the
way
the idea i would take for airlines is
the following here's an idea for you on
airlines
when you get on airlines what can you
buy
actually tell me what you can buy when
you get on airline headset booze now
they're giving headsets for free or five
bucks okay okay
food like these little snacks
i'm sorry why don't you put additional
things to buy
like you know these games that you get
for free and you buy seven hundred
dollars worth of stuff that
you know i'm in colombia with my friend
stephen awful offers like look what
steve's doing he just keeps playing this
game steve was hooked to the game
spend a few thousand i'm like what are
you buying i said well i'm buying this
because i'm trying to do this and steve
was killing it in the game but
they got they got a guy to go from
getting a free game to spending seven
hundred dollars at that people are
spending five ten thousand dollars right
why don't airlines create upsells what
is an upsell
okay if i'm up there by myself
what things do i want or do i need think
about it airline industry
what would you like to spend money on
and put tears and the tiers could be
10 bucks 50 bucks a hundred bucks 500
some people would spend the money
you're up there like hey would you like
this great i don't know what it is
but they have to figure out a way you
got 400 people on a flight
you mean to tell me you can't get 40
grand like make some money off these
undivided attention of an audience you
got stop just selling the credit cards
what other way can you make money off of
them i love those credit cards they have
to start
figuring out better ways to uh make
money off
of the customers that yeah a salesperson
they have to start looking at it this
way
if a if a financial advisor at morgan
stanley dean witter
was to be told hey every day i'm going
to give you
a hundred different audience to speak in
front of
an average audience is 400 people what
would that financial advisor say
it's freaking sick yeah that's insane
you're kidding me no
that's the airline industry how many
flights do you have a day
i don't know 100 200 500 a thousand
that's
100 200 500 000 people they can speak to
for 400 people on it what if you do
sponsorship you bring your morgan
stanley dean with a guy
that gets five minutes to speak to
everybody and morgan pays you a hundred
thousand dollars for that wow that's a
good what if you bring up
what if you bring a what if you freaking
do something with this yeah that's a
ridiculous opportunity
i don't understand what the hell these
airline industries are doing they're
thinking this same
you know old school method of running a
business is going to work dude you're
about to go out of business
you better get your act together so two
books if they're listening by the way if
anybody's in the airline industry
or knows of somebody send this short
clip or segment to them so they can
listen to this because if not
i i want the airline industry to stay in
business
i want barnes and noble to stay in
business there's certain things i want
to stay in business but they need to get
creative but the airline industry is
going to stay in different
in business the industry just some
airlines are going to go out of business
that's yeah and that was i think
jamaat's
yeah initial point is some businesses
are gonna go i just want you to get
creative and
innovative that's a great way to win we
win if people get innovative and
creative the consumer wins you and i win
i i'm gonna say this you know
some airlines just do it so much better
than others and it's so obvious so
shout out to jetblue shout out to delta
you guys clearly get it you're very good
now i'm going to make another prediction
and as we know these aren't predictions
this is like looking into history
and and already knowing what's going to
happen with mine
okay there's going to be another airline
bailout next year
2022 count on it here's why business
travel kapoot
all right now they somehow weathered it
for one year because you know coveted
shut everybody down
business travelers aren't coming back
maybe they will to a small percentage
but
business travel used to run the airlines
i mean that was the biggest part
number two they got false hope they got
a sugar high
because so many people are spending
their stimulus checks on flying so then
you got that fake thing that you're
thinking that maybe you're coming back
and i i saw a lot of people that were
using their stimulus money
to fly i saw that for about five or six
months and and leisure travels up right
now airports are crazy you may have seen
it over the weekend but that's going to
die down too
i mean because people want to get out
there and travel but that's going to
tail off a little at the end of the year
with no business travel with the
stimulus money being gone they're in big
trouble another bailout next year
i think they could be the next newspaper
if they don't
you know how newspapers went from
everybody had a new york times l.a times
whatever
usa today on the table when you went
into a business yes and now we're all
going online
i think something like that could happen
to the airline industry and
someone today someone today could
disrupt the game in a
massive way someone could pull it off
today i don't
i ho i wholeheartedly agree with you
that something needs to get done you
can't just operate
you know as business as usual like how
it's always been done or else you're
going to be a dying breed
however there's clearly some airlines
are going to win and some are going to
lose and basically what's going to
happen
is at the end of the day the consumer's
going to lose why because they're just
going to have
less options less flights less
just options at the end of the day if
two or three airlines go out of business
then you're just stuck with
american delta united whoever it is uh
and the big winners are gonna
dominate the marketplace just like in
the um the streaming wars how basically
the rich are getting richer and the
bigger getting bigger
the major airlines who are winning this
war will
divide and conquer and they'll figure it
out and there's some they're gonna just
fail like for instance
what's the airline that everyone talks
about what's the one airline that
everyone's like oh those guys
worst customer service well i don't know
what it's called but you know uh spirit
no not fair spirit yeah is it spirit
yeah
yeah is it airtran i can't hear anybody
spirit's different though because
they're targeting a different audience
you're going low budget you don't expect
high customer service from a low budget
airline
where you can't even create a business
spot and the guy's not changing no
exactly and
and people are still going to fly you're
not coming for customer service
you're coming with shitty leg room by
the way you know what i call that i call
that a business model exactly
true that's a different target there's
another one that's emerging too it's
they're going from these smaller
regional airports the former founder of
jetblue his name is alex wilcox he
started this airline
called jet sweet x if you haven't flown
on jet swedex it probably has it hasn't
come this far east yet but
amazing and there are some smart people
in the airline industry that see
opportunity they're trying to do some
different things
and that that go on service you know i
feel like you're getting threatened
every time you get on the plane
everything you can't do you'll be banned
you'll never be able to fly 35 000 fine
meanwhile you got
you know senorita and and grumpy in the
cabin watching porn
right and doing that so it's a crazy
world in the air
for the industry well don't forget back
in the eighties and nineties how long
roads
eventually lead to porn i think it's
just for sure or the cockpit yeah
i mean how many different airlines uh
merged went out of business
continental there used to be um
multiple different airlines but it's so
expensive northwest
and they emerged when they became part
of delta and then
usa usa things are busy things are going
to get consolidated adam business model
has to change what you're saying is
scary to me
let me explain to you why you don't want
that to happen okay why you don't want
that to happen
yes if these companies are screwing up
and you're buying back stocks with the
money that you got on the bailout
yes you the ceo you shouldn't be run the
company period
you should not be run the company while
you're doing that that's a bad decision
you're making that guy needs to get
fired right
but the point with my issue is if we
only have three airlines
guess who's losing the customer customer
loses
you want six seven eight options we win
when there's six seven eight options so
you would much rather have six seven
eight options that are competing
unfortunately right now
i don't see a lot of folks working on
business but like i went on these
flights i'm like okay let me see what
they're going to do differently
nothing i'm like right there right now
this is an opportunity can i ask you a
question sure
regarding your up sale idea which is a
great theory and what we've already
talked about the airline history what
about selling porn
in the air they probably make billions
now all of a sudden you're on the porn
side of things
that would need to be flip-flopped a
special session no but
let me let me let me go where he's going
let me go where he's going okay let's
just go where he's going okay even
though i'm not gonna get on that flight
but i guarantee you there's a model for
it you ready
okay let's just say an airline comes out
where all the
waitresses or what do you call a flight
attendant are dressed like the girls at
mandalay bay
they're dressed like that looters
waitresses basically let's just say
hooters waitress but i'm talking about
real nice and dressed up real sexy
you know where there's an audience for
it and then on there it's
adults only flight it's truly an adult's
only flight so no kids allowed
it's 18 and up like a resort you know
what's crazy that's a business model
that is a business model what if on a
flight now
airlines try to figure out a way to have
a casino on the flight that's a business
model
what if airlines can now get approval to
have on the flight
gambling going on what if there's a deal
what if there's a poker tournament going
on on a flight what
these are all additional ancillary stuff
that they could where someone's going to
say dude let me tell you something man
a five-hour flight feels like 10 minutes
that's how you would sell it you want to
fly from la to
miami our flights feel like five minutes
why because there's a poker tournament
going on for six hours
and a winner gets a thousand dollars
your flight's taking care of like that's
the kind of stuff that they can do
i'm just telling you there's
entertainment add some spice maybe new
music is a different genre maybe people
like
like italian music you know dean martin
type of music frank sinatra there's a
john
there's an audience for them maybe it's
an edm flight maybe there's a
i think there's so many is that what
you're saying the first five rows being
first class and the rest just being
packed in like sardines isn't a
sustainable business model moving
forward just because it's a business
model
but now that everybody else is doing it
yeah you're screwed please
differentiate you would have to spend
i'll go on that flight by the way i know
you will
figure it i know you will by the way if
i was single i would also go on the play
to miami
are you kidding me i'm going to play
poker for you you're not even going to
feel the fly like this you're landing
last thing you know one of the biggest
uh budget items for an airline is
marketing you would have to spend almost
zero on marketing you get so much free
press
i mean literally you'd be getting so
much publicity the garbage monster gave
4.99 says market a mile high club
section everybody already wants it right
yeah there it is
garbage monster you get 10 times 10x on
your 499 and we just gave you 50
on that comment that's funny so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye